wow das ist eine der krassesten news die
ich bisher hatte zum ersten mal seit 40
jahren forschung nach den signalen ist
ein signal gefunden worden
das bisher nur mit einer außerirdischen
intelligenz erklärt werden kann und es
kommt aus unserer direkten nachbarschaft
vom sternsystem proxima centauri das ist
nur 4,2 lichtjahre von uns entfernt
interviews gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
seit 1960 wird nach signalen
außerirdischer intelligenz gesucht und
nach 17 jahren war es tatsächlich von
erfolg gekröntes war am 15 august 1977
am biggi radioteleskop der ohio state
university wurde das signal aus dem
sternbild schütze empfangen es war 30
mal stärker als das hintergrundrauschen
im weltall noch heute ist unklar woher
es stammt wer es gesendet hat oder
welchen ursprung es hat allerdings gilt
in der astrophysik weiterhin es als
möglicher versuch einer kontaktaufnahme
durch außerirdische doch es wurde nie
wieder gefunden und es wird damit wohl
nie geklärt werden können wo er ist
genau kam und was es war
deshalb hat die privat finanzierte
us-initiative break kulissen in den
letzten jahren unsere galaxie die
milchstraße gründlich abgehört und
dieses jahr insgesamt 2 petabyte an
daten veröffentlicht eine ziemliche
menge an daten und wenn er signale gibt
stehen die chancen nicht schlecht dass
sie gefunden werden computer werden ja
immer schneller und effektiver und so
steigen von jahr zu jahr die chancen aus
den daten von radioteleskopen
außerirdische signale herauszufiltern
seit anfang des jahres gibt es jetzt
also diesen riesigen datensatz der bei
der suche nach außerirdischen vielleicht
den durchbruch bringen könnte und jetzt
könnte das ja tatsächlich der fall
gewesen sein denn dieses signal hat
bisher alle anforderungen an allen
signal erfüllt und es gibt keine andere
erklärung im moment insbesondere senden
wir menschen nicht auf der gefundenen
frequenz von 982 megahertz mit
satelliten oder raumschiffen das wären
ja objekte die irgendwie dazwischen
kommen könnten aber so wie es gefunden
wird geht das gar nicht das signal
verbarg sich in den insgesamt
zwei petabyte daten von radioteleskopen
die die initiative break kulissen anfang
des jahres ins internet gestellt hatte
dafür haben radioteleskopen drei jahre
lang die milchstraße nach möglichen
funksignalen abgehört die von
außerirdischen zivilisationen stammen
könnten bei der erfassung der daten war
das optische teleskop otto mit planet
feinde beteiligt und außerdem auch das
greenback observatorien in west virginia
die hälfte der gesammelten daten aber
stand vom australischen parkes
radioteleskop das mit einem antennen
durchmesser von 64 metern als das größte
bewegliche teleskop dieser art gilt und
genau mit daten dieses teleskops wurde
das signal jetzt gefunden aufgezeichnet
wurden sie für einen ganz anderen zweck
am 19 april 2009 10 begann das park
teleskop mit einer 26 stündigen
beobachtung vom proxima centauri
gefunden werden sollten so genannte
fackeln des roten zwerg sterns im
zentrum des stern systems um zu
verstehen wie sich diese auf die ihn
umkreisenden planeten auswirken dass es
besonders interessant da einer dieser
planeten eine mögliche heimat von
außerirdischen leben ist proxima
centauri b umkreist den stern alle elf
tage ist 1,2 mal größer als die erde und
liegt in der habitablen zone in der
wasser nicht verdampft sondern flüssig
existieren kann und er ist ein
gesteinsplanet also ein absoluter
kandidat für eine zweite erde die leben
beherbergen könnte allerdings nur wenn
die fackeln nicht die atmosphäre des
planeten zerstört hätten
zur routine gehört dann auch am teleskop
bei solchen untersuchungen diese daten
persönlich für das break solisten
projekt auf mögliche signale zu
durchforsten
im juni dieses jahres begann der
praktikant saints miss damit und stieß
dann erst ende oktober auf das absolut
außergewöhnliche signal es existiert
nämlich nur in diesem einen frequenzband
von neun 182,00 zwei megahertz was
absolut für ein technologisch produziert
das signal spricht denn für gewöhnlich
kommen so schmalbandige signale nicht im
weltall vor
es ist das aufregendste signal dass wir
im breakthrough listen projekt gefunden
haben weil wir noch nie ein signal
sprung durch so viele unserer filter
hatten
sagt sophia scheidt von der penn state
university die anschließende analyse des
signals für breakthrough listen leitete
und die haupt autorin eines
bevorstehenden papier ist dass diese
arbeit detailliert beschreibt und anfang
2000 21 veröffentlicht wird sprich
dieses signal hat bisher alle filter
durchlaufen die ausschließen dass es ein
natürliches signal ist ein signal
durchläuft zunächst eine flut einfache
automatisierte tests um offensichtliche
terrestrische störungen auszuschließen
hunderte von kandidaten bestehen diese
phase jedoch und werden weiter
untersucht allerdings scheiden die
signale dann auswahl an anderer
natürlicher grund für das signal
gefunden wird außer dieses sagt eick und
noch etwas macht das signal so
außergewöhnlich break solisten verwendet
eine technik namens nicken bei der das
teleskop eine zeit damit verbringt ein
ziel und dann eine gleichwertige periode
anderswo in den himmel zu schauen um zu
überprüfen ob jedes potenzielle signal
wirklich vom ziel kommt oder nicht im
fünf der 30 minütigen beobachtungen über
etwa drei stunden sehen wir wie dieses
ding zurückkommt sagt schenk ein
weiterer hinweis darauf dass das signal
tatsächlich vom proxima centauri oder
einer anderen weltraum quelle in diesem
teil des himmels stammt bevor es zur
erde gelangt und damit mit all diesen
eigenschaften ist es eine absolute
premiere blc wann der brakes kulissen
candidate one das erste signal der
breakthrough listen initiativ das
wirklich von einer außergewöhnlichen
intelligenz stammen könnte und es weist
weitere sehr seltsame eigenschaften auf
die die forschung durchaus war und sich
an erstens trägt das signal keine spur
von modulation optimierung an seinen
eigenschaften die zur übertragung von
informationen verwendet werden können
glc one ist in jeder hinsicht nur ein
ton nur eine note sagt andrew simeon von
der university of california berkeley
es hat absolut keine zusätzlichen
funktionen die wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
erkennen können und zweitens driftet das
signal was bedeutet dass es sich in der
frequenz leicht zu ändern scheint ein
effekt der auf die bewegung unseres
planeten oder einer sich bewegenden
außerirdischen quelle wie eines senders
auf der oberfläche einer welt wie
proxima centauri zurückzuführen sein
könnte aber die drift ist das gegenteil
von dem was man von einem signal
erwarten würde
das von einer welt stammt die um den
nächsten nachbar stern unserer sonne
wirbel wir würden erwarten dass das
signal wie eine posaune in der frequenz
sinkt was wir stattdessen sehen ist wie
eine rutsche die frequenz steigt so
sophia scheidt
die gesammelten daten also diese zwei
petabyte sind weiter im internet zu
finden und somit können sich weiterhin
alle bei der suche nach hinweisen auf
außerirdische kommunikation beteiligen
denn klar ist mit dieser riesigen
datenmenge könnte es weitere signale
geben die hoffnung ruht darauf dass sich
andere fachleute anschließen und bei der
suche helfen schon im sommer 2009 10
hatte die seht die initiative erst der
daten veröffentlicht seitdem hat sich
die gewonnene datenmenge allerdings
verdoppelt und die fachleute sind
weiterhin optimistisch zudem soll die
suche noch ausgeweitet werden auch die
radioteleskope des very large array in
den usa sollen demnächst bei der
fahndung nach außerirdischen signalen
mit am start sein
dazu werden spezielle module installiert
dazu der forscher industrien dieses
interface wird es uns erlauben eine
leistungsstarke weit gefächerte seht ihr
durchmusterung durchzuführen die weit
vollständige ist als alle bisherigen
suchen dieser art der große vorteil hier
kann bei normalem betrieb der teleskope
quasi mitgehört werden zudem ist das
system in der lage auch ergänzende
analysen der daten durch zu fünf
ensembles außerirdischen signal entdeckt
anklicken anschauen und krieg zum
science im future abonnieren cola kanal
auf youtube es lohnt sich auf jeden fall
bis dann bleibt dran